bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 20 mars abdullei web deviendra le
nouveau président de la république du
sénégal abdou diouf quitte le pouvoir
après 19 ans de présidence le pape jean
paul ii est arrivé aujourd'hui en
jordanie première étape qui en comptera
six au proche orient avec des attentes
contradictoires en israël et cisjordanie
comment faire pour préserver les
retraites dans les décennies à venir le
plan jospin sera annoncée demain il n'y
aura pas de bouleversement un peu moins
de morts que l'année dernière sur les
routes en france mais tout de même 8029
tué beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup
d'accidents de moto
et puis après la défaite du quinze de
france hier face à l'irlande entre
remise en cause des joueurs et
grincements des dirigeants du rugby
français perd ses illusions
au sénégal c'est donc une alternance
politique tranquille et démocratique on
a tellement pris l'habitude d'évoquer
les coups d'états africains qu'il
convient ce soir de souligner ce qui
vient de se passer au sénégal où
l'opposante toujours abdoulaye wade
vient de mettre fin à 19 ans de
présidence d'abdou diouf
le successeur de léopold sédar senghor
et monsieur abdou diouf très normalement
a reconnu sa défaite et félicité le
vainqueur ce qui a provoqué quelques
scènes habituelles d'enthousiasmé
militants à dakar reportage de nos
correspondants permanents en afrique
eric monier roger motte
ceux ci étaient encore cet après-midi
tout à l'ivresse de leur victoire celle
d'abdoulaye wade
le candidat de l'opposition celle du
changement de l'alternance dans ce
sénégal qui n'a connu depuis
l'indépendance en 1960 que deux
présidents léopold sédar senghor et
abdou diouf tous deux membres du parti
socialiste
aucun débordement se tendent aujourd'hui
dans les rues de la capitale
un contraste saisissant avec la liesse
de la nuit dernière
le dépouillement dans les 8500 bureau de
vote est loin d'être achevé mais déjà
les partisans du candidat de
l'opposition ont compris les milliers de
jeunes gens se rassemblent devant la
maison d'abdoulaye wade
awad qui bientôt apparaît pour se
proclamer président élu la fête peut
commencer tandis que le vainqueur est
train son allié moustapha niasse
l'ancien ministre d'abdou diouf entré en
dissidence
sans doute le futur premier ministre
vers midi les dernières incertitudes
sont levés le président sortant a
téléphoné à son successeur pour le
féliciter
dans les quartiers populaires de dakar
comme ici à la médina où l'on peut
parler de raz-de-marée en faveur de wad
c'est l'après diouf qui commence et
l'espoir
d'abord d'une amélioration rapide des
conditions de vie je pense que le la
croissance dont parlait au delà le
président sortant va se transformer en
quelque sorte en une amélioration soit
au niveau de la population voit la jeune
espoir
le prix nobel dans les plasmas gevaert
la jeunesse même les plus optimistes
redoutait ce lendemain d'élections on
attendait des résultats contestés il en
a rien été
on craignait des fraudes c'est en
réalité le visage d'une démocratie
apaisée qu'a offert le sénégal le
sénégal désormais un modèle pour
l'afrique pendant six jours le pape jean
paul 2 sera au proche orient la terre
des religions monothéistes où il compte
délivrer des messages de paix dès son
arrivée aujourd'hui en jordanie
le souverain pontife est évoqué le
processus de paix en réponse à son hôte
le roi abdallah ii qui parlait d'une
visite porteuse d'espoir pour tous ceux
qui n'ont connu que les misères du passé
isabelle staes et dominique merlane nous
font le compte rendu de cette première
journée du voyage du pape en jordanie
le rituel est immuable mais il revêtit 6
pour jean paul ii un sens profond
c'est la terre sainte que le pape penny
et prend dans ses mains et c'est l'image
d'un vieux rêve qui se réalise
le pape s'est déclaré excité par ce
voyage ils n'avaient pas de souhaits
plus cher que ce pèlerinage aux racines
de la foi qui commet city en jordanie
terre à majorité musulmane réputée pour
son hospitalité sa tolérance
au jeune souverain hachémite le roi
abdallah dont le dessin père hussein a
toujours oeuvré pour le dialogue au
proche-orient besoin jean paul ii
extreme dès son arrivée tout le sens de
sa présence
promouvoir la paix dans une région où
elle se fait toujours attendre
bonjour il y à de graves et aux jambes
questions concernant la justice le droit
des plugs au réseau lui dit le souverain
pontife
peu importe la difficulté le processus
de paix nous pour nos joueurs
la jordanie entretient depuis longtemps
des relations sans nuages avec le
vatican
l'accueil est chaleureux environ 200
mille chrétiens vivent ici en harmonie
avec les musulmans
une terre qui n'a jamais connu de
conflit interreligieux et sur laquelle
se trouve le monde est beau c'est sur ce
lieu présumé de la tombe de moïse que
jean paul ii ce recueil dédiant au fait
qu'à chaque pas de son voyage en terre
sainte
selon la tradition ici du haut de cette
montagne
moïse by la terre promise avant de
mourir jean paul ii y contemple leur a
longuement de l'autre côté du jourdain
jerusalem la jordanie représente
assurément l'étape la plus consensuelle
du voyage de jean paul ii mais c'est une
semaine à haut risque qui s'annonce car
le vatican a beau répéter qu'il s'agit
d'un pèlerinage exclusivement spirituel
et que le pas bien ici sans suggestions
formule politique en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens le souverain
pontife devra trouver le juste équilibre
entre son désir de rapprochement avec
les juifs
son soutien aux palestiniens et son
appui à la minorité chrétienne
c'est en effet demain soir que jean paul
ii sera en israël laissait à partir de
ses premiers pas dans ce pays dans toute
la cisjordanie que l'aspect politico
religieux de son déplacement sur
révélera car palestiniens israéliens ont
des attentes parfois contradictoires
d'autant que de part et d'autre les
extrémistes n'ont pas l'intention de se
taire
correspondance charles enderlin
c'était en fin de matinée devant le mur
des lamentations des prières contre la
venue du pape
ces trompettes en argent appartiennent
au mouvement pour la reconstruction du
temple juif à la place des mosquées le
who's who extrémistes religieux étaient
là baruch marzel de l'implantation juive
de hébron se tint diligent du mouvement
raciste carte qui est officiellement
hors la loi nous n'avons pas eu
l'autorisation de manifester aux
endroits où sera le pape alors je crains
que certains commettront toutes sortes
d'actes pour exprimer leur douleur d'une
autre manière dédiée les gens ultra
orthodoxes craignent justement de tels
actes à considérer j'ai lancé un appel à
notre communauté ils devront avoir le
sens des responsabilités nous aussi
parce que des juifs vivent tanger dans
des pays catholiques
nous devons veiller à ne pas porter
atteinte à l'honneur du pape et j'espère
qu'il ne se passera rien au même moment
à l'autre bout de la ville les
palestiniens déclenché leur bataille de
jérusalem mais politique
cette cérémonie s'est déroulée à la
maison de l'orient où se trouve la
représentation de localités exprimer
notre joie pour la venue du pape
donc on sent que nous avons un rendez
vous avec sa sainteté le pape à la même
année on nous avons un rendez vous avec
l'histoire à savoir la naissance de
l'état palestinien
le ballon a été retiré à la demande de
la police israélienne qui a reçu l'ordre
d'enlever tout emblème palestinien qui
pourrait flotter à jérusalem est
ce sont des drapeaux israéliens qui
décorent la rue où logera jean paul ii
est aujourd'hui commis hier pendant ce
temps l'armée israélienne a procédé à
des tirs d'artillerie à partir de la
zone de sécurité de suivi dans trois
civils libanais ont été blessés dans ce
village dans ces habitations du village
de arbouche rassurer ou quasiment de
remporter l'élection présidentielle
russe dimanche prochain le président par
intérim vladimir poutine multiplient les
interventions pour pour de la
tchétchénie monsieur poutine a effectué
aujourd'hui une visite surprise à grozny
où il s'est rendu en avion de chasse
il s'est dit à la fois prêt à négocier
avec les combattants indépendantistes
mais également favorable à ce que les
combattants qui refuse de discuter soit
étranglée sur place aujourd'hui à
bruxelles l'union européenne a renouvelé
sa profonde préoccupation sur la
situation des populations civiles en
tchétchénie quant à brice fleutiaux le
photographe français il est toujours
retenu en otage depuis le 1er octobre 99
le premier ministre lionel jospin est
aujourd'hui à toulouse pour la signature
d'un contrat de plan entre l'état et la
région midi-pyrénées mais plusieurs
milliers de manifestants enseignants
agents du trésor ou encore chômeurs sont
venus se rappeler à son attention
reportage muriel de la saga et olivier
combe
la motivation était bien là très fort
parfois
3500 d'un côté 6000 de l'autre beaucoup
d'enseignants tout cas venu manifester à
toulouse pour faire tomber les milliards
en haute garonne
pas question d'abandonner après une
semaine de grève et d'actions dans tout
genre surtout le jour de la visite de
lionel jospin dans la ville rose
alors toujours rien obtenu puisque les
déclarations de jose peine
c'est un milliard pour milliards pour
l'école série m vis-à-vis du budget de
l'éducation nationale
cette fois ci les enseignants
brandissent le symbole de la menace
une sorte de chantage relayée par des
parents d'élèves toujours aussi
mécontents 1 que le mans ou forme de
violence à l'école on nous parle de
fracture nous parler d'échec scolaire
alors maintenant les effectifs et
réduisant le nombre de l'enseignant est
ce que vraiment on pour résoudre ses
problèmes non le cortège a rejoint
d'autres manifestants postiers agents
des impôts un jour de grogne sociale à
toulouse que lionel jospin aura à peine
entendu le quartier du conseil régional
étant entièrement quadrillé le premier
ministre a simplement rappelé l'effort
considérable fourni jusqu'à présent pour
l'éducation nationale seule réponse pour
l'instant
la reconduction de la grève jusqu'à
vendredi et tandis que l'on notait une
reprise des cours dans le gard les
enseignants des écoles primaires et
maternelles de l'hérault mener leur
grève dans le rhône du lycée
d'enseignement professionnel est
également touchée par une grève
d'enseignants 800 millions de francs
dans le budget 2000 pour construire
trois nouvelles prisons en france 200
millions pour rénover certains tribunaux
ces nouveautés budgétaires ont été
annoncés par un bijou ce matin chez manu
guigou qui a précisé que pour un cas il
s'agissait d'une prison supplémentaires
à lyon au total en deux ans et demi 10
nouvelles prisons ont été construites
c'est demain que lionel jospin doit
présenter son plan sur les retraites pas
de bouleversement laisse-t-on entendre
mais plusieurs hypothèses dont celle de
retraite progressive ou à la carte alors
explications avec 24 heures d'avancé sur
ces pistes destinées à conforter les
régimes de retraite
avec elsa palau
alain juppé s'était cassé les dents sur
le dossier en 95 plus de quatre ans
après lionel jospin lui aussi confronté
à l'épineuse question des retraites
mais cette fois le sauveur c'est
peut-être lui michel baud le pdg de
france télécom car l'action du groupe
français détenu à 63 % par l'état a
grimpé plus voir exploser et le
gouvernement compte bien profiter de
cette manne miraculeuse pour alimenter
le fonds de réserve pour l'avenir des
retraites sauf surprise le gouvernement
ne semble pas décidé à vendre ses
actions
il préférerait transférer ses titres
france telecom dans ce fonds de réserve
ou seulement y verser les dividendes
une chose est sûre lionel jospin veut à
tout prix conserver le principe de la
retraite par répartition les cotisations
des actifs devrait donc continuer à
payer les pensions des retraités
mais nouveauté le premier ministre veut
mettre en place une sorte de retraite à
la carte
chacun pourrait partir plus tôt avec des
pénalités moindre qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
déciderait de rester plus longtemps
accumulerait eu de nouveaux points avec
des possibilités de départ progressif le
gouvernement envisage également de
revoir la durée de cotisation pour les
régimes spéciaux mais il mise sur la
négociation branche par branche
enfin dernière innovation lionel jospin
devrait annoncer la mise en place d'un
observatoire chargé de surveiller et
d'anticiper l'évolution financière des
retraites
que ce soit dans le secteur public ou
privé pour garantir les retraites
on n'échappera sans doute pas un
allongement de la durée des cotisations
actuellement les plus de 65 ans
représentent près de 16 % de population
française environ 9 millions 400 mille
en 2020 un français sur cinq aura plus
de 65 ans outre cette donnée
démographique salariés du public et
salariés du privé ne rompt pas les mêmes
préoccupations
alors voici deux témoignages recueillis
par cyrille devaud joseph baltique celui
d'un enseignant est tout d'abord celui
d'un retraité qui vient d'ouvrir un
restaurant
louis jacques vannuchi aime partager son
amour de la cuisine traditionnelle et du
bon vin richard donner
google en revanche pas question de
partager son argent pour alimenter les
caisses de retraite avant d'ouvrir son
restaurant de 40 couverts
il a cotisé pendant dix ans en tant que
salarié c'était avant de comprendre nous
dit il qu'il cotise est beaucoup pour
les autres et que tout compte fait il
n'était même pas sûr de toucher sa
retraite sans son heure serait venu la
retraite par répartition aujourd'hui il
ne veut plus en entendre parler
je suis absolument contre un tel système
j'estime que j'ai droit à ma liberté mes
choix je veux faire ma retraite tout
seul comme un grand
et je ne veux pas défendre et encore
moins être assujetti à les lois qui va
fait d'être le gêner non pas que je
veuille être égoïste mais je suis alors
je fais partie des individualistes et
les gens pour qu'ils aient un esprit
libéral veut donner les moyens de se
faire sa propre retraite aujourd'hui 10
actifs cotisent pour quatre retraités
dans 40 ans le rapport sera de 10 pour
cette si rien ne change d'ici peu il va
manquer de l'argent dans la caisse il
faudra donc allonger la durée de
cotisation pense claude beauchaud
professeur de biologie cellulaire à la
faculté de jussieu dans six mois il
prend sa retraite
comme tous les agents de la fonction
publique il n'a cotisé que 37 ans et
demi contre 40 ans pour les salariés du
privé
claude beauchaud souhaite donc
l'alignement à 40 ans pour tout le monde
et la création d'une retraite par
capitalisation au drak la retraite par
capitalisation s'ajoute en fait à la
retraite classique
donc je pense qu'il va probablement vers
les deux systèmes qui se surajoutent la
halle avec l'autre conscient d'être
privilégiés claude beauchaud partira en
octobre avec une retraite à taux plein
vingt-trois mille francs par mois ce
n'est donc pas pour lui qu'il s'inquiète
mais pour ses enfants
les propositions du ministre des
finances concernant la réforme de bercy
est rejetée par les agents des impôts et
le syndicat force ouvrière appelle même
à une grève générale demain une nouvelle
rencontre est prévue entre les
fédérations syndicats d'une part
christian sautter et florence parly
d'autre part déception politique pour la
gauche après les résultats des élections
législatives partielles
hier dans la sarthe les pyrénées
atlantiques le pas de calais l'issue du
premier tour la gauche pouvait espérer
trois victoires finalement la droite
garde de
siège commentaires alban nicosie avec
jean francois monier la déception à
gauche on voit là illustrer la parabole
des châteaux en espagne premier épisode
à flot où le candidat socialiste est
battu de justesse mais je crois qu'en a
perdu 3,75 mois c'est peu mais suffisant
pour que la droite conserve le siège
présenté comme très menacée de françois
bayrou
son suppléant pierre menjucq lui succède
à l'assemblée nationale et voilà le
président de l'udf tellement soulagée
qu'il a passé une partie de la soirée au
téléphone à propager la nouvelle les
victoires les plus serrées sont les plus
belles et pour nous ce soir
c'est un moment d'émotion et de joie
comme il y en a eu depuis longtemps par
la politique dans la sarthe
la droite a encore plus de mal à cacher
sa joie le r clair jean marie geveaux
obtient plus de 51% des suffrages dans
une circonscription détenue par un
socialiste
ce proche de françois fillon semble
avoir profité d'une forte abstention à
gauche
incontestablement les électeurs de
gauche ont un peu boudé cette élection
parce qu'ils sont vos mécontents de
l'action du gouvernement
finalement la seule bonne nouvelle pour
la gauche vient du pas de calais les
socialistes jean claude le roy a ravi à
la droite de ses fiefs la
circonscription de l'ancien ministre
philippe vasseur cette circonscription
était réputée imprenable et ce soir nous
avons réussi avec avec cette population
et tous ces militants je veux dire un
incroyable résultat battu assez
largement la candidate rpr brigitte de
prémont a regretté l'absence dans la
campagne de philippe vasseur celui ci
est bien venu voter mais retiré de la
vie politique il s'est bien gardé de
tout commentaire
le ps et le parti communiste ont signé
un accord national en vue des élections
municipales de mars 2001 15 villes sont
encore en discussion entre eux une
première journée parisienne pour le roi
du maroc mohamed 6 avec notamment deux
entretiens entre président chirac et le
jeune roi commentaires jean-marc il use
avec jean-paul chaussée
brel 3h30 d'entretien publics et privés
aujourd'hui à l'elysée entre le roi
mohammed vi du maroc et le président
jacques chirac échanges officiels et
personnels à la fois à l'image des
relations privilégiées qu'entretiennent
la france et le maroc tant sur le plan
économique que politique
la france tient à accompagner dans la
durée les difficiles réformes que
prépare le jeune souverain chérifien
huit mois de règne des gestes
symboliques pour réconcilier les
marocains rassurer les
laissés-pour-compte de près de 40 ans de
monarchie absolue mais il faut désormais
imaginer une remise à plat économique et
social du maroc sans rupture brutale
mais aussi sans retard un effort que le
maroc entend faire aux côtés voire même
dans l'europe une europe où la france
serait son meilleur avocat
mais pour désamorcer une nouvelle banque
sociale dans le maghreb et éviter que la
minorité islamic soit la force politique
la mieux organisée de l'opposition
marocaine
il faut que l'intendance suive la france
est prête à aller plus loin pour aider
le maroc en termes de dette en termes
d'investissement et ce soir à l'accueil
avec sympathie la candidature marocaine
à la coupe du monde de football en 2006
dans la volonté affichée de réforme ce
royaume médecis a multiplié les
déclarations et des gestes en faveur des
femmes
une commission sur le droit des femmes
doit maintenant chercher un compromis
entre les islamistes conservateurs et
les progressistes qui manifestaient tous
les deux chacun de leur côté le dimanche
12 mars dernier le débat est ouvert
il porte aussi bien sur l'interdiction
de la polygamie que l'égalité entre
hommes et femmes en code divorce ou
encore de décès reportage au maroc
bernard lebrun et philippe turpault mari
elle a envie de faire ce qu'il veut pas
votre lettre
voilà parce que telle est la loi au
maroc l'homme pouvant rejeté son épouse
en quelques minutes cette jeune femme se
retrouve sans ressources ni logement il
en charge avec ses enfants par cette
association
la moudawana le code du statut personnel
et de la famille date de 1957 et voici
le fameux projet de réforme du
gouvernement qui sous la vè divise les
marocaines
il propose d'instaurer un véritable
divorce judiciaire et d'abolir les
privilèges ancestraux des hommes la
réplication est une prérogative qui
reconnut au mari de mettre fin pour
contrat de mariage de manière
unilatérale
donc sans demander l'avis de son nez aux
et pour n'importe quelle raison
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
maroc des femmes mais aussi des hommes
ont osé descendre dans les rues pour
demander le vote de cette réforme
prudent et free le gouvernement tarde à
la présenter au parlement est née renée
aussi là pour que les lois ancestrales
change des slams et pour le progrès pour
la femme
il est content la polygamie on peut bien
sûr discuté on peut à la vision faut
interpréter mais on sait que le grès
tendances et les lacs et pour le propre
mais à chacun son islam le courant
politique islamiste ne partagent pas la
même vision du progrès à ce meeting qui
a rassemblé plus de vingt mille
personnes
les intervenants clairement rejeté la
réforme l'accusant de détruire la
famille musulmane
coatex politiques disent les
progressistes le fait des courants
islamistes ont fait une démonstration de
force et se sont imposés en qualité
d'interlocuteur
le fait de marcher à casablanca c'était
surtout pour pour leur dire vous avez
ignoré jusqu'à 13 ans maintenant il est
grand temps qu'on dialogue
d'un côté les islamistes de l'autre les
démocrates mais au maroc on refuse de
parler de fracture de la société les
gens ils ont hurlé d'un côté les autres
monnaies de l'autre chacun des vendanges
en point de vue mais c'est ça le jeu de
la démocratie et c'est la preuve que le
bourreau et fort comme francis efforts
moins d'un an après son arrivée au
pouvoir le jeune roi fait le pari du
débat démocratique
mais c'est finalement à lui que le
gouvernement à demander d'arbitrer le
débat sur le statut de la femme en
allemagne les chrétiens démocrates
veulent vite tourner la page des
affaires de financement de leur parti
sous helmut kohl et ils viennent de se
prononcer en faveur de la candidature
d'une femme angela merkel à la
présidence de leur parti olivier werner
elle a conquis le coeur des militants de
droite avec sa coiffure à la jeanne
d'arc
angela merkel nouveau porte drapeau de
la cd ou en lieu et place de vols
conjoints le contraint à la démission
emporté par le scandale des caisses
noires
c'est une petite révolution culturelle
dans ce parti avant tout masculin
catholique conservateur de l'ouest
son curriculum vitae fait couler
beaucoup d'encre depuis plusieurs
semaines ce qui est écrit c'est qu'elle
est divorcé remarié sans enfant
est-allemande et protestante
ce qui n'est pas écrit c'est kelly dur
est courageuse car si elle est sortie de
l'ombre c'est pour prendre ses distances
avec son maître à penser
helmut kohl qui pendant des années l'a
surnommé la gamine
aujourd'hui la gamine à 45 ans a déjà
été vice présidente de l'ate cd ou
ministre de la condition féminine puis
ministre de l'environnement à 37 ans
angela merkel prend aujourd'hui la
direction d'un parti à la dérive sous le
coup d'une amende de 70 millions de
francs à payer sans délai celle que l'on
compare désormais à margaret thatcher ne
regardera plus jamais elle ne colle avec
ses yeux doux la gamine à tuer le père
pour voler de ses propres ailes
euronext c'est le nom que portera partir
du mois de septembre prochain le
regroupement des bourses de paris
amsterdam et bruxelles cette fusion
baptisée euronex donc sera la deuxième
place boursière européenne après londres
1360 sociétés seront cotées sur cette
nouvelle place qui pourrait en
accueillir bien d'autres explications
jean bernard schmidt et benoît duquesne
ils ont le sourire de ceux qui viennent
de faire un joli coup ces trois pas de
comptes bourse ont décidé la fusion des
marchés financiers de paris amsterdam et
bruxelles
un regroupement annoncé comme par hasard
à londres premières bourses européennes
petit un pied de nez diront les uns une
main tendue pour les autres equity
derivatives c'est un geste vis-à-vis de
beaucoup de nos clients qui sont
effectivement ici et chats peut-être
effectivement aussi un appel du pied
fausse paris saïss may be forced also
because mais pour séduire les anglais il
faudra faire des efforts
leur montrer l'intérêt d'euronext le
nouvel ensemble boursier pèse 2200
milliards d'euros moins que londres mais
déjà plus que francfort
surtout il jette les bases d'un futur
grand marché européen
car il y va des places financières comme
des entreprises à plusieurs on est plus
puissant et plus économes
la technologie et leur pérennisation des
marchés font qu'il était naturel que
l'on ait accès à une plateforme plus
large et une plateforme européenne
ce qui est important c'est qu'avec cet
accord ce sera plus facile et moins cher
pour l'instant rien ne change pour les
investisseurs le cac 40 l'indicé des 40
premières valeurs françaises reste le
même grâce à cette fusion les
actionnaires pourront désormais acheter
en toute liberté des titres français
belges et néerlandais le bilan routier
pour l'année 99 n'est pas très bon 8029
mort c'est mieux que l'année dernière
évidemment mais le nombre de
cyclomotoristes est un peu tués est en
augmentation et la france reste dans les
pays les plus mal classés en terme de
sécurité routière française vallée avec
pierre moscovici
moins de morts sur les routes en 99
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais il faut
savoir qu'en 98 la nuit avait été
particulièrement meurtrière on revient
en fait au chiffre de 97
les chiffres encourageants mais
l'objectif du ministère est de passer en
dessous des 5 mille morts par an
l'alcool la fatigue et la vitesse
restent les principales causes
d'accident les routes nationales et
départementales représente 80 % des tués
il ya donc moins de risques sur
l'autoroute mais les automobilistes
peuvent mieux faire notamment en
attachant leur ceinture de sécurité
il ya 40 % des tués sur les routes qui
ne portait pas de ceinture je viens
débat effectivement j'ai oublié vous
faites bien de me le dire jeune harvey
salameh herpy contrairement aux idées
reçues les femmes sont plus prudentes
moins d'accidents six fois moins de
délits que les hommes font testons tout
roule
on met pas mattely pitot dans le vert
dans le volant
en revanche les chiffres sont toujours
mauvais pour les deux roues en
particulier les scooters les petites
cylindrées et même les vélos c'est pas
bon vélo paris sera bon
pourquoi tous les gens sont trop fou
trop pressé les campagnes d'information
sont donc prévus pour améliorer ce bilan
qui fait de la france un des plus
mauvais élèves des pays d'europe en
matière de sécurité routière
deux nationalistes corses membres
présumés du flnc canal historique ont
été condamnée à 11 ans et cinq ans de
prison dont un avec sursis
comparaissait devant la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris pour des attentats
commis entre fin 96 et début 90 7 et
puis réquisitions dans le procès à
toulon pour recel d'abus de biens
sociaux contre l'ancien sénateur maire
maurice
rex 4 ans de prison ferme ont été
demandées en belgique réapparition sous
bonne garde de marc dutroux il était
jugé ce matin pour les faits commis lors
de son évasion en avril 98 le t2 fils
avait réussi à s'échapper du palais de
justice de neufchâteau qu'il a donc
retrouvé ce matin il a essayé d'échapper
pour alerter les médias sur les
conditions de sa détention at il dit
compte rendu de cette audience yasmina
farmer et olivier julien à l'arrière du
palais de justice de neufchâteau la
tension monte
c'est d'ici que marc dutroux avait pris
la fuite ce 23 avril 98
c'est ici qu'il est jugé pour les faits
liés à cette évasion évasion
rocambolesque
seuls deux gendarmes assuraient la
sécurité de l'ennemi public numéro 1
belge ces trois heures de cavale
coûteront les sièges des ministres de
l'intérieur et de la justice
mais au delà des circonstances de cette
fuite cette première audience a permis
d'entendre la voix de marc dutroux
l'homme qui a fait frissonner d'horreur
la belgique sous l'oeil attentif de son
avocat il montre beaucoup d'assurance
je n'ai même pas effleuré d'un ongle le
gendarme du trou ce n'est pas sa version
répond la présidente c'est un menteur
rétorque que le prévenu
le ton est donné et il va plus loin je
me suis échappé parce que la pression en
prison était intenable c'était pour
contacter des journalistes faire passer
un message
quelques soient leurs parents ce qui
wii sports à l'audience ça sera toujours
l'apparence inadéquate
6 il est trop calme il est trop calme
s'il est excité il est vraiment désolant
enfin je veux dire que il a un rôle
important à jouer ce rôle de victime du
trou leur a joué trois quarts d'heure
mais da sa sortie une voix lui rappelle
que l'image du gourou lui colle à la
peau
c'est la mère d'une fillette retrouvée
vivante dans une case elle aussi voyez
dutronc pour la première fois très sûr
de lui presque insolent marc dutroux
était heureux de s'exprimer pour la
première fois depuis quatre ans
publiquement il dit attendre avec
impatience son procès en assises pour
mettre les pendules à l'heure mais la
date de ce procès n'est pas encore fixée
en ouganda le président museveni promet
des sanctions contre les dirigeants de
sectes qui mettent en danger la vie de
leurs fidèles c'est la réaction
officielle après le suicide collectif
des sectes ici à cannes boucetta plus de
300 km au sud ouest la capitale kampala
le dernier bilan fait état d'environ 400
morts et près de 4 dont près de 80
enfants à la veille du débat de la
seconde lecture du débat parlementaire
sur la loi trautmann concernant
l'audiovisuel les producteurs de films
scénariste techniciens se sont réunis à
paris au palais de chaillot pour dresser
la liste de leurs doléances il souhaite
une augmentation des quotas de création
française et le doublement du budget dé
télévision de service public
reportage ce film est celle de frédéric
de la rue trente ans qu'on ne les avait
pas vus ensemble les acteur producteur
réalisateur télé mais l'occasion était
grave même si cette réunion a parfois
pris des allures de one man show la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans est barrée
avec la caisse et je dis que c'est une
honte
après tout ce que nous avons fait pour
elle toutes les précautions qu'on a
prises pour ne pas la choqué tous les
efforts de bassesse dans l'écriture des
sujets des heures et des heures des
centaines d'heures de télévision
médiocre qu'on lui a fabriqué sur mesure
et voilà l'europe la naissance pour
refuse donc improvisé aujourd'hui porte
parole de la profession
il s'agissait de dénoncer le manque de
risques pris par les chaînes au nom du
sacro saint audimat
mais aussi la faiblesse des moyens mais
la disposition de la création et c'est
vrai tout particulièrement dans le
service public
même si je consacre 10 7% de son chiffre
d'affaires et à la création française
soit près de 800 millions de francs
cette vision est scandaleusement sous
financé on sait depuis des années c'est
la moité de la bbc le tiers la
télévision publique allemande
oui il ya un problème propre aux
services publics mais le problème de
déperdition de la créativité il est
générale toute la télévision française
en dessous est là où se développe tous
azimuts des nouvelles chaînes le câble
satellite internet
la profession est vrai que l'on se
préoccupe de leur contenu et par la même
occasion de leur financement
elles redoutent en particulier d'être
négligés par la loi trautmann examiner à
nouveau demain à l'assemblée
deux prix prestigieux ont été remis pour
honorer deux jeunes comédiens tout
d'abord le prix romy schneider à
clotilde courau que vous avez peut-être
vu dans le film rend phase de mathias le
doubs et puis le prix jean gabin à
guillaume canet puis dans la plage et
l'on verra bientôt dans le film de
zulawski la fidélité du cinéma donc avec
mercredi sur les écrans un film du
réalisateur marco bkis marco béquille
c'est un ancien enseignant argentin dans
son film garage olimpo il raconte ce que
fut un centre de torture et de détention
sous la dictature argentine en plein
centre de buenos aires est à la fin des
années 70 c'est un film de fiction bien
sûr mais à partir de faits réels
maintes fois dénoncée par amnesty
international présentation de garges
d'impôts avec pascal deschamps et pascal
couillaud
somme de la policière
et les figurines des pièces comme des
dizaines de milliers d'autres argentins
maria a été enlevé un jour d'été disparu
aux yeux du monde
elle fut la pensionnaire du garage à
l'info les cris des victimes torturées
dans ses sous-sols
on ne les entendait pas depuis la rue le
réalisateur marco bkis a connu les
souterrains les interrogatoires
l'électricité professeur opposant cet
italien d'origine a été expulsé garage
l'impôt c'est une descente dans l'enfer
des oubliés au moment même où
l'argentine accueillait le monde entier
pour la coupe du monde de football
il ya eu qu'une culture expressif
dans les films les suspensions imagine
c'est plus dur parce qu'on imagine avec
notre fantasme avec notre fête et en
reste avec cette impression de violence
c'est pas la violence du cinéma c'est
pas la ville à ce camp comme utilise
dans l'esprit mac commercial c'est pour
les familles des trente mille disparus
que marco bkis a finalement tourné le
film même si l'argentine a connu
quelques procès la grande majorité des
tortionnaires sont aujourd'hui en
liberté ni remords ni regrets car pour
tout un pan conservateur de la société
en amérique latine la torture est un
outil de gouvernement
il suffit de reprendre ce que disait le
général videla de ce point de vue là le
premier chef de la junte argentine celui
qui reste et 76 à 80 il disait que
terroristes et pas simplement celui qui
tient le pistolet la bombe
c'est aussi celui qui professent des
idées qui sont contraires aux idées
chrétiennes et occidentale terrifiante
banalité des mots qui cachent de
véritables crimes contre l'humanité
après des jours de séquestration maria
et finalement jetée vivante d'un avion
au large des côtes
un sort partagé par des milliers de
citoyens ordinaires garage de l'impôt
c'est mercredi sur les écrans du sport
avec un retour sur une défaite qui fâche
le rugby français a perdu ses illusions
et hier sur la pelouse du stade de
france et les jeunes irlandais ont bien
mérité leur victoire mais maintenant
toutes les interrogations sont possibles
sur les joueurs du quinze tricolore
comme sur la méthode de leur entraîneur
bernard laporte reportage christophe
duchiron avec frédéric bazille il fut un
temps le coq gaulois emblème du quinze
de france faisait le beau sur les
terrains mais au stade de france se fait
belle pelouse
les bleus ont enregistré hier leur
cinquième défaite consécutive cette fois
face aux irlandais 27 à 25 vers impair
et père pour gagner encore eût-il fallu
que les français marc haas mais c'est là
que le bât blesse et la triste à dire
mais les bleus ne sont plus efficaces
des problèmes dans la finition le match
des occasions manquées à la fin du match
est une évidence il manquait des points
tricolores au tableau d'affichage
comme d'habitude la défaite soulève des
questions certains se demandent qui est
devenu le french flair ce sixième sens
qui échappait aux lois naturelles du jeu
et qui parfois faisait la différence
d'aucuns parlent aujourd'hui d'un jeu
prévisible et stéréotypé ce qui aux yeux
de l'entraîneur bernard la force n'est
pas vraiment le problème aujourd'hui et
croyez moi on a tous envie de pratiquer
un rugby le rugby d'aujourd'hui laurie
buts et fait d'affrontements et
d'évitement monchy comme il s'est bien
produit hier au stade de france c'est
pas un ni dans l'affrontement d'aller
vite mais nous n'avons pas été bon hier
c'est d'abord de la défense et qui était
notre point fort l'étude hier a été
certainement notre secteur qui nous a
fait perdre en effet si le jeune
trois-quart centre o'driscoll numéro 13
a crevé l'écran en marquant trois essais
il a trop facilement crevé l'écran la
défense française
il s'agit là d'un domaine qui demande
beaucoup de cohésion mais sachant le
nombre de blessés donc de nouveaux
joueurs
les bleus ont manqué d'automatismes dans
ce secteur en fin de match en voyant les
français mais physiquement on a repensé
au calendrier trop chargé
mais apparemment ça n'est pas vraiment
le problème mais bon je suis pas là pour
polémiquer sur le calendrier ou quoi que
ce soit au moins j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir cette semaine de vacances et je
suis pas là pour faire les comptes
coincés ou j'accepte de venir je
donnerai mes yeux bleus je suis je dit
oui je suis prêt à 100% je le mets pas
quoi faut que chacun y mette mais se
mettre devant ses responsabilités
aujourd'hui il faut pas pleurer un peu
en cours de partie
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si on gagne a
pas de revenir sur une thèse sur un tel
sujet c'est comme ça mais c'est surtout
quand il perd que le rugby français a la
capacité de se remettre en question il
va donc falloir faire vite pour trouver
des solutions sur votre le coq bien
quelques plumes et aujourd'hui à nice
bernard lapasset président la fédération
française de rugby a confirmé la
suppression de la coupe de france et
puis monsieur lapasset entend bien
discuter la modification des calendriers
internationaux
enfin pour le premier jour du printemps
des écoliers américains et français est
ensemble au parc de versailles pour
planter quelques arbres dont un tulipier
cèdre chauve tulipier marquant ainsi le
début du reboisement du parc choc
dévastée par les tempêtes de la femme
avait 99 la cérémonie fut ouverte par
les hymnes nationaux américains et
français en présence notamment de line
renaud
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je vous rappelle trois événements
d'actualité que nous avons développées
tout d'abord abdoulaye wade deviendra le
nouveau président de la république
sénégal abdou diouf quitte le pouvoir
après 19 ans de présidence pour une
alternance tranquille le pape jean paul
ii est arrivé aujourd'hui en jordanie
une première étape qui en comptera six
au proche orient et des attentes
contradictoires en israël et cisjordanie
et puis comment faire pour préserver les
retraites dans les décennies à venir le
plan jospin sera annoncée demain mais il
n'y aurait pas de bouleversement en
quelques secondes patrice dauvin vous
dira tout sur la météo de demain suivi
du dernier épisode remarquable du film
victoire ou la douleur des femmes le
film de nadine trintignant avec marie
trintignant marina vlady blanc brèche
ensuite jean 12h35 le magazine d'arlette
chabot et alain duhamel mots croisés qui
aura pour thème les impôts avec comme
invités notamment alain madelin françois
hollande
edouard balladur et robert hue à zéro
heure quinze vous retrouverez le journal
de la nuit présentée par laurence
ostolaza demain 7 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevoir monsieur
jacques barrot à 13h ici même carole
gaessler et rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir
m
je